wer also schon seit längerem es wird
aber von jedem tag oder von tag zu tag
eigentlich schlimmer und zwar politische
correctness was darf comedy heutzutage
noch was darf man überhaupt noch sagen
ich als jemand der natürlich sowieso
komiker ist er polarisiert und das
andere sagt was wo manche sagen oder ist
kann er noch nicht sagen drauf genau das
ist jetzt natürlich noch viel viel
schlimmer in einer diskussion und was
man machen kann und es gibt sozusagen
kein rechtsfreien raum mehr wie es zum
beispiel auf der bühne sein müsste also
es muss einfach möglich sein auf der
bühne sich über sachen die auch
politisch unkorrekt sind einfach drüber
lustig zu machen aber wenn ich jetzt
hier zum beispiel bin muss ich ja schon
gucken was ich sage weil ich da wird was
abgeklappert was rausgenommen aus dem
zusammenhang gesetzt und dann muss man
sich das anhören oder auch sachen die
man vielleicht vor 10 12 15 jahren
gesagt oder gemacht hat und dann wird
daraus natürlich eine bewegung die
natürlich auch gerade im comedy bereich
dann in diese gewisse cancel culture
geschichte geht dass man sagt aber
damals das um das gesagt und dafür sich
darüber noch lustig machen und da habe
ich also unzählige beispiele könnte ich
jetzt stundenlang darüber reden aber das
ist so ein grundsätzliches thema und es
wird nicht besser machen und jetzt zum
beispiel auch heute alleine ich zum
beispiel
verfolgt das auch in afghanistan und
mein ansatz war zum beispiel weil ich ja
so absurd fahren dass die taliban
pressesprecher haben ich hätte gerne ein
einspieler gedreht wie ich der
pressesprecher der taliban bin und halt
auch so mit begrifflichkeiten aus dem
fußball er so hin und her schmeiße weil
hier auch den sponsoren kann man seine
sponsoren wand machen und ich fand auch
diese bilder wie das erste mal autos gut
gefahren sind das ist ja schon comedy an
sich wenn hier auf diesem den sitzen so
wir lachen drüber wir haben gerade paul
ronzheimer da gehabt und es gibt leute
die hier stehen es ist tragisch dann
kommen aber wieder da sterben leute da
darf sich darüber lustig machen aber es
gibt auch wiederum sachen die er
befreiend wirken und über die man sich
lustig machen sollte oder auch muss aber
da kommen sofort ein und sagt ja da ist
aber auch dass und das passiert und du
machst jetzt darüber lustig was dein
lieblings
wahnsinnig war ich ehrlich gesagt wir ja
kein klassischer wird zusätzlich aber es
gibt sehr viele situationen hatten sehr
schwarzem humor das weißt du wir beide
auch wenn man mal sich lohnt oder das
eigentlich noch dazu war ich hätte dich
also ist es ist ein nicht in dieser
sendung zumal pigmentiert auch humor wie
man ja aber wir sind mittendrin ist
genau das ist ein völlig normaler roma
ist dass schwarzer humor warum kannst
nicht weißer humor sein oder binärer
humor ja nicht binäre von nicht
genannten person sitzt du da man sich
mit seinem programm und geest nochmal
drüber und lässig sozusagen dann gar
nicht mehr aber man merkt mittlerweile
auch wie man eine gewisse schere
natürlich im kopf hat bzw merkt bei
sachen die man so ganz normal sagt aber
so kann man hier ja da kann ich dir auch
wird neben gerade ist egal wo du hier
bist du nur irgendwo sitzt oder so oder
einer macht nur so das ist hier ja muss
jetzt schon aufmerksam haben mach ich
eher sexuelle belästigung bei diana oder
ist es umgekehrt und die nehme ich auch
gerne an aber das ist natürlich schwer
irgendwann ich denke anzeigen in 30
jahren
in drei jahren hat sich die pandemie
auch noch irgendetwas verändert sind die
menschen die deutschen ernster geworden
möglicherweise noch weniger humorvoll
also nee also allgemeine nein es ist
natürlich genau das gegenteil aber das
ist ja auch so weil immer mehr leute ich
habe ja in gewisser form auch von
profitiert indem ich ja social media
mäßig durch die zeit die ich hatte ja so
viel schwachsinn gesehen aber ich sagte
warum hat er noch nie eine so richtig
was zu gemacht und das wird ja mehr und
mehr und es wird schlimmer und schlimmer
und jedes mal denke ich auch so jetzt
hab ich alles gesehen dann kommt das
nächste ding allerdings ein dass das
kann doch nicht es kann doch nicht sein
das habe ich doch das haben wir doch
noch so noch nicht gesehen und die leute
sind natürlich jetzt übers internet wir
merken sie einen ganz vielen situationen
es wird sofort entschieden gerichtet du
musst dich sofort positionieren bist du
für den sie den komiker lustig oder
nicht steht und auf der seite oder nicht
bist du für frauen oder gegen frauen
möchtest du für jemanden der irgendwie
people of colour wie es politisch
korrekt heißt ist bist du die für jede
randgruppe erreichbar und die diese
ganzen randgruppen haben die möglichkeit
über aufrufe und über indem sie sagen so
jetzt hat er das gesagt jetzt hat er das
set bot das android das wort das f wort
gesagt können sie halt sofort dafür
sorgen dass auch beruflich langfristige
konsequenzen entstehen und da haben
viele ja auch angst zu recht dass wenn
sie das untersagen das ist ein
schwieriger wird immer schwieriger
geworden insgesamt wieder
selbstverständlich das problem finde ich
auch manchmal dass hinterher also ich
finde janine kunze war für mich auch ein
sehr gutes beispiel als diese sendung
die einfach nicht bombe war ihm einfach
man müsste noch mal nicht doch finde ich
auch ehrlich nun auch in der sendung
roja aber im endeffekt hinterher wie
damit umgegangen wurde also ihr wurde so
viel reden von der letzten instanz als
oder genau es wurde wurde so viel hass
entgegengebracht und im endeffekt ging
es eher ums hinrichten als im endeffekt
um die debatte erst ging nicht mehr
darum was war das ein fehler wir können
wir darüber reden wie können wir das das
besser machen sondern es ging eigentlich
nur darum wie bestrafen werden konnte
dass sie am besten ihren job verliert
ihr leben verliert nie wieder im
fernsehen auftreten darf es wurde
hinterher im endeffekt geht es immer nur
um die bestrafung und nicht mehr um die
eigentliche thematik und das ist einfach
keine gesunde debattenkultur aber das
ist ein ganz ganz wichtiger punkt leser
hass im netz und ich habe mir heute
schon vorgang heute morgen du heute
abend ihr gast bis oliver sich also eine
sache frage bitte und ich finde es auch
super wichtig mit dem man darf nicht
mehr alles sagen aber wann beginnt
mobbing
ich meine es nicht auf dich bezahlt doch
diese deutsche kontrolle gerne aber es
gibt eine ska nicht öffentlich sagen wo
ich schon manchmal als mobbing findet
dass es jan böhmermann aber nicht oliver
pocher ich finde ich immer sehr lustig
aber wann ist es mobbing und wann ist es
noch humor aber da wird sie nicht
inwieweit jan bürger man mobbing
betreibt oder so ist es seit das ist in
der in der ansichtssache also es war
schwierig aber
aber ja aber das ist halt aber in
gewisser hinsicht tut ist ja muss es
manchmal auch weh tun also zum beispiel
bei mir ging sein letztes jahr los mit
michael wendler der danach eigentlich
das bestbezahlteste mobbingopfer aller
zeiten hätte werden können wenn er nicht
so blöd gewesen wäre aber das sei normal
dass steht also ich selber im wege und
dann da man zum beispiel auch bei mir
diese ganzen influenza und leute auf
instagram sensationell haben sie alle
den winter filter irgendwie ins gesicht
geknallt sich selber betroffen war super
und als man gesagt hat was man auch hier
macht übrigens auch scheiß werbung und
eure produkte sind bekannt und irgendwie
immer dieselben bilder und ihre pflicht
nach dubai obwohl pandemie ist und jetzt
macht der schnee bilder obwohl es ein
gar kein schnee bild man machen sollte
dann fand es doof und dann ist sofort
mobbing und das ist immer so ein
leichter her geworfener begriff also ich
finde mobbing ist halt so einer schule
oder irgendwo leute die sich nicht
werben wehren können aber leute die ich
angreifen oder bitte ich mich lustig
mache haben eine reichweite zwischen 10
bis
6 millionen verloren und die müssen
einfach für das auch konfrontiert oder
müssen davon mit konfrontiert werden und
haben auch eine chance irgendwas dazu zu
sagen ein problem notiert werden für das
was sie selber aus eigenen stücken ins
netz stellen das ist immer noch ein ganz
gewaltiger unterschied als zu jemanden
der schule gefilmt wird gemobbt wird das
ins netz gestellt wird und darunter
20.000 leute kommentieren das ist ein
anderes ist ein unterschied als welches
handy nehmen und sagen so das ist meine
packten die ich mir ins gesicht
schmieren das ist einfach ein ganz
gewaltiger unterschied das macht man aus
eigenen stücken und dann muss man wenn
man in dieser branche stattfinden wir
das wollen sie ja alle sie wollen ja
irgendwie bekannt seien und sie wollen
ja ein gesicht werden dann machen sie
das ja auch und dann muss man damit
rechnen dass dann auch mal ging jetzt
hätte ich ja das mobbing beispiel dann
noch aber bitte klaus möchte was sagen
ich wollte euch nur daran erinnern dass
wir müssen abgeschweift sind willkommen
also zusagen für eine politik was man
überhaupt dahinter so morgen konnte ja
politik correctness und die
zustandsbeschreibung ist glaube ich so
wie sie ist man muss heute mehr
aufpassen was man sagt das ist für
komiker comedians besonders schwierig
aber wie geht s wieder weg gar nicht ist
es auch fast gar nicht es wird also
amerika sein vorbild da sie zum beispiel
so das hat schon gewisse komik
es gibt zb der fc pel der in sehr
krassen um mord und auch viele andere
das zum beispiel so wenn die handys
weggeschlossen vorher das ist irgendwann
wird das vielleicht der nächste step
werden also wenn du auf eine
veranstaltung geht von einem comedian
dass du einfach vorher die handys es
gibt dann auch so die es gibt systeme
und amerika zum beispiel wenn hier nicht
rein gemacht sobald es auf machst gibt
es die leute speed geräusch dann hast du
zwar ein handy aber du musst das
weglassen damit einfach nicht mit
gefilmt werden kann aus dem zusammenhang
guck mal da hat einer das gesagt damit
gewisse sachen entstehen dass es dann
einfach passiert an dem abend auf der
bühne machen wir alle drüber oder halt
auch nicht und das war's dann das ist
traurig es ist traurig aber wir können
ja ich weiß nicht ob es wieder
zurückgeht das ist ja wir aber wie immer
leute ist auch die presse nicht ganz
unschuldig es wird natürlich auch ein
klick dating
verfolgen wo man sagt so fies lästerten
oder dann ganz schlimm für euch
natürlich gerade auch bei bild wenn es
noch gebühren finanziert ist dann ist er
diesen gag haben wir mit gebühren für
gab es schon dauner wo man sagt ja okay
bei extra 3 oder so es war letzte woche
kann man gut finden oder nicht aber es
ist eine satire sendung kann man muss
man nicht jeden tag gut finden kann man
aber trotzdem dann auch machen gibson
geld dem oli pocher jetzt auf keinen
fall machen würde weil er einfach im
ohren immer im analogen oder läuft
eigentlich noch immer oft gibt es leider
fast keine grenzen das ist das schlimme
das darf man zwar auf den aufhängungen
ich weiß keiner mit nein aber es ist
halt auch bei der größten tragik aber
auch ich kann das auch bei mir selber
sagen also auch wenn mir irgendwas
schlimmes passiert oder irgendwas nicht
so gut läuft oder so irgendwie dann dann
ist doch relativ zügig mache ich da halt
auch ein gag darüber also das ist das
ist halt einfach ein vielleicht auch ein
gewisser form des schutzmechanismus dem
mann hat das heißt ja trotzdem nicht
dass man nicht empathisch ist oder
irgendwelche sachen nicht gut oder
schlecht findet man weiß natürlich der
öffentlichkeit über manche sachen kann
man einfach keine witze machen sollte
man in öffentlichkeit nicht machen aber
privat ehrlich gesagt da sind die
lautesten lacher oft wenn man da
irgendwo sitzt und sagt mensch ihr sowie
sitzen weil direkt machen wir mal so
eine oli pocher privatparty hier aber
das ist das wollt ihr nicht hören also
ihr wissen doch auch sachen von leuten
privat und so einen unterschied ob man
die weiße urlaub man sie druckt so
[Musik]